last time in the good Star Trek movie oh
no God escaped from his prison a new boy
called Genesis that creates life in two
seconds but still can't create a good
Sonic game in year with the alley as a
Vulcan she does well that's just plain
weird
revenge is sought after and Shatner says
Khan's name like he's passing a kidney
stone what this Spock is sacrificing
himself for the crew it appears this
Balkan wants out of this franchise will
he be sucked back by the fact that he's
the most marketable character stay tuned
same star trek time main Star Trek
Channel
[Music]
in continuing with Star Trek month we
now peek a look at Star Trek three
search for top
the unknowable the odd number Star Trek
movies this is probably the one that
people say come close to actually being
pretty good but it still lacks the epic
rivalry of two or the clever comedy of
four and so on its own is it worth
searching for let's find out this is
Star Trek three so we open up with a
recap of the last movie and we discover
a rather effective way to save money on
your opening credits just play your
previous movie backwards yeah who needs
big special effects when you can simply
push the rewind button on your last film
we don't cut to Kirk who is still shaken
by the loss of his Vulcan body but most
of our battle damage repaired we're
almost home yet I feel uneasy and I
wonder why well it's either the bean
burrito that might be giving you
indigestion or the fact that your best
friend just died I don't know maybe it's
the burrito a hero's welcome sounds
empty like what God knows it should be
we then cut to elsewhere in space where
a klingon played by Christopher boy is
gathering info on the Genesis project
stand up apparently he buys his animals
from Gosar's at shopping aquarium that
thing is so cute I'm gonna name him
Paula
hello Balzac how are you doing and
apparently he's so important to the
story that he even gets his own scene
you're done
yeah wasn't that vitally important I
couldn't see the story moving forward
unless we knew that ball that got fed
it's the crux of the movie jump in pick
badly too bitch what LFO it's not -
Thomas come on
they add 3.5
boy she sure taking that whole gotta
kill you thing pretty well not even a
plea or an escape plan or a darn she
just fully accepts it Kindles only more
people were accepting of death yeah
right well we've been waiting for okay
put it on screen high critic sidebar guy
yeah well would you think it was going
to be oh no one I thought was going to
be link art anyway what's up well I got
that copy of Star Trek five that you
want oh that's right I don't have a
copier because I only try to own good
movies yeah well you know being a sci-fi
nerd it's kind of required by law that I
own everything Star Trek even the really
bad stuff like the Christmas special he
is a Christmas special yeah it's only
legally viewable in Amsterdam so uh you
want the movie oh sure upload to my
computer there ya go
let me tell you your review of this I'm
sure is going to be just as funny as
mine you're planning on reviewing it too
well yeah it is kind of my stick
unfortunate I know what that means
that I'm totally cool with it I mean I
totally love to die on your behalf and
be thruster I think it's so awesome
you're going to kill me like this I mean
I can hardly wait just let me into
oblivion you will be remembered with on
earth really wait before you do that I
am transferring my life savings into
your bank account
hell I'm not going to need it anymore oh
well thank you very very kind of you
also I should just let you know that I
had all of my family members signed up
to be your personal slaves after my
passing anything else I can do for you
you know wash your windows shine your
shoes Oh No thank you to more than
enough sci-fi guy God you understand you
the situation is unbelievable
well I know it's for a good cause and
hey just good luck to you man you too my
friend you fired
sylvie Enterprise returns to the space
dock when checkoff suddenly discovers a
human life form in Spock's quarters I'm
on my way lord knows the security team
doesn't go in first
it's too scary they're only dressed for
in case a 1940 football game breaks out
but it turns out it's dr. McCoy who is
actually convinced that he himself is
Spock
help me Joe take me home bones we are we
are home then perhaps it's not too late
you can still stop me from saying yes to
transformers 3 the Laura I get the
medics down here as developed by doctors
Carol and David Marcus Genesis simply
put his life from lifelessness seek
impression oh my god is that John
Larroquette it is John Larroquette is a
Klingon on Star Trek I surprisingly have
little material for that sure we were a
kid as a quaint how am I supposed to do
with gel or a cat I got going on I mean
it's strange enough to notice but
doesn't really lead it's way too many
comedic possibilities I'm kind of struck
um here's the triple in nightcore you
want the perfect work with meanwhile
Kirk is visited by Spock's father who
isn't too happy why did you leave him on
Genesis stop trusted you and you denied
him his future well he wanted all the
franchise it made no request of me he
would not have spoken of it openly bring
that which he gave you his Carta his
living spirit the mark I must have your
thoughts so he does a mind meld with
Kirk but doesn't find the answer teeth
looking for
crowd look at all the green-skinned
whores is this all your mind is filled
with about Neha
it is not here so the mind of spock is
an incurred then where is it
well how about in the mind of the guy
who thinks he Spock but no that'd be too
obvious
we need clarification of this by going
over to the nicely shot and edited
security camera footage remember so
McCoy finds he's of two minds on
everything what do you think here's a
good old journey to the bar will shut up
both voices in his head oh yeah
fuck all of Duty these are the games of
the future take a look if you like
seeing what will come you our planet
welcome hi here I'm new I named not
important you seek I message received
are you hitting on me how much how soon
how much where Genesis Genesis you know
maybe you could say your lines a little
easier if you stop imitating the voice
of stitch Genesis Genesis good if I
could I offer you a ride home dr. McCoy
where's the logic in offering me a ride
home you idiot if I wanted a ride home
would I be trying to charter a flight ah
no I think he just farted you know I
think this guy's butt is where his mouth
should be I'm not entirely sure
Federation security sir I'm gonna get
out a nice long rest
well Kirk and Sulu go to break him out
as they try to get into the Genesis game
cache planet which has just become
forbidden Oh keeping you busy
don't get smart tiny
[Music]
don't go me guiding anytime you want to
use the word tiny just youth or decay
instead the Kobayashi Maru has set sail
for the promised land so a good chunk of
the gang feel the enterprise with
Starfleet not far behind
commanders pamphlet on the emergency
channel he orders you to surrender this
vessel well I have no idea what a
whistle is so I can surrender it Kurt
you do this you'll never sit in the
captain's chair again
well technically his contract has them
for three more movies so that's very
unlikely pair for warp speed standby
transwarp Drive too many years from one
surgeon to another I took them out of
the main trends what computers right now
yes and be over-the-top cartoony vehicle
sound of thing well that was just all
ops we then cut to the Genesis yeah no
cache planet as Kurt son David and not
Chrissy Ally look over there Commodore
64 graphics and notice that a life-form
is down there so they head on down to
check it out while it's white after
traveling for a while they finally come
across the life-form which makes no
sense when they just be into its exact
location and they see that the life-form
is in fact a younger version of Spock
with no memories and no means of speech
God like Courtney Love after a few
drinks but then the evil klingon come in
to ruin the day haha
come on pull Johnson there now who are
we gonna eat
it's risen if you work life signs on the
planet
perhaps the very scientists you seek so
the Klingons being themselves down to
the planet where the others are several
miles away from where the others are you
know the logic behind teleporter doesn't
make much sense and you're the fun
little development it you're the Spock
is going through punk bar which Star
Trek history suggests that Spock has to
mate with something in order to survive
oh well that can only mean one sizzling
conclusion okay time to do the spot rub
those fingers the caress though from
that don't touch those knuckles the rub
of all over that what the inside her
wrist and gently work your way around
you you know this isn't very sexy I mean
is this really all we see this is Star
Trek we think Kirk make out with God
knows how many ladies and yet for Spock
we get sort of this half-assed eg6
I'm sorry I thought we'd get something
more steamy
[Music]
böck when a pretty lady asked you to
finger her this isn't what she means
yeah look fuck fuck the Klingon cock
blockers come in and ruin the hell let's
face it they didn't ruin anything I've
come a long way for the power of Genesis
king fish what do I find
a weakling human a Vulcan boy and a
woman sounds like the beginning of a
joke at a size icon Confederation
starship approaching bring me up someone
goes back up to his ship and gets ready
for battle that distortion said yes it's
getting largest enclose it aqua dashi
wash their different notice by the way
that all his Klingon pronunciation is
very similar to a cat puking up there
haha
shields run is fun Scott it the
automation overloaded I didn't expect a
curtain to come back you know yeah
because stealing a starship and being
hunted down by the entire Federation
would ever put you in a situation where
you need to defend yourself
so the Klingon fire at them they fire at
the Klingon both are unable to use their
weapons and they find themselves at a
stalemate and this leads to probably one
of the most senseless disturbing yet
emotional death scenes that has ever
come out of any Star Trek film
[Applause]
precautionary mr. Chekov screenwriting
bastard you kill my home screenwriting
bastard you killed my ballsack
oh you murdered me but Charlie boy was
character what oh oh it hurts some get
killed as a means to force him to
surrender II and very tragic but he's
been right after you like all that Oh
nobody told me this was gonna be like
Marley and Me I say I'm sorry I I need a
minute to recover from this here's some
products whoring themselves out for your
pleasure
okay I think if I think I've recovered
so as you can imagine nothing can top
the dramatic explosion that was the
death of dear Bozek they reach the
height of dramatic tension people
there's no way they're going to top it
that's we get it the blowing up of the
Starship Enterprise it says the Klingons
get on board and the heroes watch from
the planet whoo-hoo well great now that
actually the bullying of of the
enterprise is pretty epic and they give
it a lot of weight too I especially like
the build up when boy puts together what
the self-destruct countdown means the
ship appears to be deserted how can that
be you're hiding but the bridge seems to
be run by computer let me hear
my god phone but hell I done what you
had to do what you always do turn death
into a fighting chance to live could sum
up his whole career with that line so
they five Spock and not Christie alley
and tried to save them however they're
still without a ship and the planets
about to blow so he makes a deal with
wine I have what you want
I have the secret of Genesis gen named K
you can have to bring us up there to get
it bite my pointy aquata entire head not
all weapons look so cute
so he beans most of the team aboard
believes himself Kirk and Spock on the
planet you fool look around you the
planet destroy yourself
yeah accelerating isn't it if we don't
help each other we'll die here
perfect that's the way it shall be
okay sorry I wasn't meaning to attack
you but then the ground raised up and
well I just decided to own it yeah I
think all the straps on Shatner's girdle
would break if he pulled that stunt off
more of his balls so he hanged him up a
cliff and finally doesn't tell them they
take control of the Klingon ship and
takes back home to the planet of Vulcan
there are on a Siegfried and Roy stage
they talk about making the transition
from McCoy's mind back into Spock's what
you seek has not been done since ages us
and then only legend your request is not
logical forgive me July my logic is
uncertain where my son is concerned well
I guess the OL logic based society says
logic only holds wait some of the time
and they decide to do the transition
spot wakes up okay and walk around in a
robe from us all I have been and ever
shall be your friend yes shit out of
danger you save the ship I blew it up
later but Jim
name is Jim so spot gets his memory back
to Cain cops a feel and we're not so
subtly told the adventure continues for
the needs of the franchise outweigh the
needs of not kicking a dead horse
so that's Star Trek three the search for
Spock and honestly I don't think it's
that bad I mean okay it's not as good as
some of the others and it does drag at
times but you've still got some big
death scene some strong moments and it
does feel very operatic at times I think
the major thing missing is that it
needed a villain along the lines of
Conda really completed and even though
Lloyd is a lot of fun easy break a bad
guy character is just sort of a one-note
not I think a really strong rivalry
would have made it a lot more epic
overall though I think it's still pretty
good I can see how others may find it
boring but I think the strong stuff
still stands out it's not the best
we've got enough goodness it's just that
the adventure continues
so this Star Trek I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
[Music]
canisters